six weeks after revealing its
controversial policy the home office has
asylum seekers it wants to send to
rwanda in detention
charities believe around a hundred
people are at four centres including
kong brook near heathrow
kez is a lawyer representing three
detained asylum seekers including a
sudanese man who says he fled to avoid
conscription and war
for the first time we get a sense of how
those who could be the first to go to
rwanda are feeling
uh this is miserable we are suffering
we do anything
we tell everybody to know that about we
are here why does it bring us here why
does
speaking through a translator another
detainee from iran says before he
crossed the channel he had no idea he
could get sent to africa
and then sending me a way to to a
different country that i don't know if
that i cannot point it on on a map
and and that would be very inhuman
the divisions that i'm dealing with they
have legal representative legal
representation so we can assist them and
challenge it but um
i don't know what's going to happen to
the numerous other individuals who don't
have a legal representative who are not
being provided with advice and who are
just left in the dark so you think it's
inevitable that people will get sent to
rwanda
that's what it seems like unfortunately
we've obtained the letter which is being
sent to asylum seekers at risk from the
new policy it warns we may share your
personal data with rwanda in order to
ask rwanda another country we consider
to be safe whether it would admit you in
a deal signed by the home secretary
rwanda has agreed to take asylum seekers
from the uk and offer a new life to
successful applicants but human rights
campaigners question how well they'll be
treated
since the start of the year around 9 000
asylum seekers have crossed the channel
the government hopes its strategy will
break the trade of smugglers lisa
holland sky news